[Music]
greetings 3abn family my name is Ricky
Carter I'll be your host welcome to
another 3abn today Bible Q&A we've got
another hour pack program with your
Bible questions and you know what we've
got the answers here in the word of God
that our panelist will be sharing and
let me introduce you to our panelist to
my right we have sister Shelley Quinn
welcome sister it is always such a joy
to be here thank you for sending in your
questions and it's our privilege to get
to respond to them amen amen and next to
her we have brother Daniel morone
welcome brother thank you so much
appreciate it being on the program today
amen and next to him we have Pastor John
deny welcome brother thank you it's a
blessing to be here and again we have
lots of good questions and we thank you
for sending them amen amen well you know
before we actually read the word of God
we want to start off with a word of
prayer so Pastor deny could you lead us
with prayer please yes let's go to the
Lord in prayer Our loving Heavenly
Father We Want to Thank You Lord because
any time of the day we can come before
your throne of grace and you are ready
to listen to us and we thank you Lord
that you are so wise so all knowing
that you know what is best for each and
every one of us and you will not give us
anything that will be of harm to us only
that which will be to our benefit amen
we thank you for that and we ask you now
for the blessing of your Holy Spirit we
desperately need the blessing of the
Holy Spirit we pray that you will give
us the words to speak and we also pray
that your children will be blessed
wherever they may be may they become
more interested in learning about you
and learning more about the Holy
scriptures which you have given to us to
help us understand where we came from
and why things are happening and how you
are going to deliver your children we
ask you for all these blessings in the
holy and blessed name of Jesus amen amen
amen amen well Pastor deny I've got your
first question but actually before I
share that with you want to remind our
viewers at home how you can participate
you can participate with one of three
ways you can email us to Bible QA 3m. TV
that's Bible QA
3m. second way is you can text us to 618
3975 that's 618 228
3975 and a third way for those of you
who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions in that way as well at
3abn official at 3abn official all right
Pastor deny here's your first question
all right why does God allow so much
suffering for one person that's from Don
in Wisconsin who texted that to us well
thank you Don for your question and um
we would need more information to try to
figure out what type of suffering you're
indicating it sounds like either you're
suffering or someone you know is
suffering and you are touched by it and
in this world there are many factors
that cause suffering and I don't know if
this is the case but sometimes people
cause suffering upon themselves I don't
know which case this is but the Bible
does say uh that as a man sow so shall
he reap and there are people that
because of some habit like smoking or
drinking now they're experiencing pain
and suffering because of things they did
this may not be the case but know that
God is a loving God and the Bible says
that God is love amen and so we have to
ask ourselves why does he allow certain
things to happen we are in a great
controversy between good and evil and a
certain amount of things God has to
allow so that people understand that
evil is not good evil doesn't do any
good to anyone and this is something
that must be done away with and this is
why you have a wonderful message in
Revelation chap 21 and I was not going
to go there but I'm going to go ahead
and go there Revelation 21 I want to
show you this first before we read some
other scriptures to get a background in
Revelation 21 beginning in verse uh one
uh the Bible tells us and I saw a new
Heaven and a new Earth for the former
for the first Heaven and the first Earth
had passed away also there was no more
sea then I John saw the holy city New
Jerusalem coming down out of Heaven from
God prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and I heard a loud voice from
Heaven saying behold the Tabernacle of
God is with men and he will dwell with
them and they shall be his people God
himself will be with them and be their
God and God will wipe away every tear
from their eyes amen there shall be no
more death nor sorrow nor cry amen amen
uh that uh there shall be no more pain
amen for the former things have passed
away God doesn't want anyone to suffer
he does not enjoy suffering and really
the Bible presents to us a picture I
think it's in Isaiah 63 that uh even
when his children are afflicted he is
Afflicted when they suffer he suffers so
this is because of the great controversy
between good and evil Satan is here and
he is out to uh steal kill and destroy
uh so again God has to allow certain
things to happen in order for people to
understand that sin is something that
has to be eliminated but notice some
scriptures uh for example Psalm 23
notice what it says in verse four yay
though I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death I will fear no evil for
you are with me your rod and your staff
they comfort me God wants to comfort all
those that are suffering reach out to
him and ask him to be with you and he
will give you strength and it's amazing
I have seen people they are going
through horrible things horrible
diseases the threat of death is upon
them yet they have peace in their heart
why because Jesus is in their heart
there's more to add but I encourage you
to go to Isaiah 26:3 and 4 amen amen
thank you very much sir all right
brother morone here is your first
question one of the 10 Commandments is
Thou shalt not kill but when I read the
Book of Judges God himself sends a judge
to kill Kings in order to deliver the
children of Israel there are other
stories where the kings are killed how
do you explain this couldn't God have
used other ways to get rid of those
kings and other people and that was
emailed to us all right well thank you
for that question whoever emailed that
in that is a good question I'm sure
other people are wondering same thing
you know the uh word for kill in the
Hebrew it's uh rasak and it actually
means uh to murder and so you could
actually translate that commandment as
Thou shalt not murder and um this is
having to do with the character of God
when you're looking at this question
here so in 2 Peter chapter 3:9 it says
the Lord isn't slack concerning his
promise as some men count slackness but
is longsuffering to us were not willing
that any should perish but that all
should come to repentance you know God
knows the heart he knows the heart of
each person he knows whether they would
ever be converted or be safe to be saved
Jesus said in 2 Corinthians 6:2 behold
now is the accepted time now is the day
of salvation Harden not your hearts in
Hebrews 3:15 says while it is said today
if you will hear his voice Harden not
your hearts as in the day of provocation
and then Hebrews 3:13 but exhort one
another daily while it is called today
lest any of you be hardened through the
deceitfulness of sin so these verses
warn us that our hearts can become so
callous that they aren't able to respond
to the love of God any longer and his
government God's government sustained or
functions on Selfless Love MH
selfishness is out of harmony with his
kingdom and will eventually destroy
itself
we have the examples of Judas who hung
himself and then Saul who fell on his
own sword to end his life you know God's
mercy and longsuffering are seen in his
dealing with Cain who actually murdered
his brother Abel you know God was the
true ruler for the nation of Israel and
he's Sovereign he knows all the judges
were his soldiers his servants we say
that Israel was living under a theocracy
because of God being knowing all and God
was ruling but by having his servants
destroy these individuals and Nations
they were helping God to put an end to
sin so we're not living under theocracy
anymore but we are to cooperate with God
and allow him to work through us as his
soldiers and put death to sin in our own
lives amen there's actually a great
controversy going on currently and then
Satan he wants us to hold on to
selfishness or sin so that we will be
destroyed with it praise God for Jesus
who's crying out out look unto me yes
and be ye saved all the ends of the
Earth for I am God and there is none
else and that's Isaiah 45:22 thank you
again for that question amen amen amen
thank you
sir all right sister shelle I've got
your first
question is it a sin to disbelieve God
that's from Gloria in Georgia oh Gloria
I wished I knew exactly what you're
saying here's what I'm going to how I'm
going to answer I don't know when you
say to disbelieve God if you're talking
about like atheism who don't believe
there is a God if you're talking about
doubt or if you're talking about
questioning god so let's look at this
John
3:16 through1
18 Jesus said for God so loved the world
he so loves you that he gave his only
begotten son that whoever believes in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life so they're either going
to perish utterly be destroyed or have
everlasting life for God did not send
his son into the world to condemn the
world but that the world through him
might be saved he who believes in Him is
not condemned but he do who does not
believe you said is it a sin of
disbelief he who does not believe is
condemned already that's a sin because
he has not believed in the name of the
only begotten Son of God so for
salvation to occur humans are required
to have a
relationship with God we are to be in a
father child relationship john2 says as
many as receive Jesus as Savior to them
he gave the right to become the children
of God and we've seen and we know that
we God's whole plan is for us to depend
upon him for righteousness by faith this
is a relational term it is how God
relates to us and how we relate to God
we can't gain righteousness by our own
personal efforts it's a gift from God
we're saved by grace through faith
listen to this Romans 3 we all know
Romans 3:23 all of sin and fallen short
of the glory of God comma you got to
keep going Romans 3:24 says being
justified freely by his grace through
the Redemption that is in Christ Jesus
so God has offered this wonderful gift
he came down to take on our human flesh
to die for us if you don't believe in
him yes it is a sin
now how about doubt doubt dishonors God
it is the opposite of trusting Faith
doubt is unbelief it's focusing on the
circumstances rather than on God's
promises James says in James 1:6-8 let
him ask in faith with no doubting for He
Who doubts is like a wave of the sea
driven and tossed by the wind for let
not that man suppose that he'll receive
anything from the Lord he's a
double-minded man
unstable in all of his
ways Paul said in Romans
14:23 whatever is not from faith is sin
so here's the point when we believe in
God we make God the object of our faith
don't have faith in faith but we make
God the object of our faith and we are
saved
so if you understand how much God loves
you you can't help but love him back
I've got to fit this last category in is
it a sin to question God no not at all
questioning is a sign of
willingness that we will learn from him
and grow God is a perfect father he even
says come let us reason together he's
longsuffering with children think of job
and so if if your question is it a is it
a sin to question God no there's times
that people have like job why me Lord
what have I done that's just a sign that
you're growing amen amen yes thank you
sister all right Pastor deny I've got
your second question can you please
explain Exodus 20: 26 someone said this
is talking about women going up on the
Rostrum in church not properly dressed
that's from Robin in Massachusetts who
texted that to us thank you Robin and I
would like to go to Exodus chapter 20
verse beginning verse 25 and then 26 and
if you make an altar of stone you shall
not build it of human stone for if you
use tool on it you have profaned it nor
shall you go up by steps to my altar
altar that your nakedness may not be
exposed on it
so if your question is was this
originally written to talk about women
going up to the roster church not
originally but there's a principle found
here that helps us understand that we
need to be careful when we are
ministering for the Lord be they men or
be they women and here it's talking
about your nakedness may not appear and
so we have to ask ourselves today how do
we see this today how can we evaluate
this to help us understand what God is
expecting of us when we are ministering
and I I'm going to add here even being
in public we should not let our
nakedness be seen anywhere amen either
men or women and
unfortunately uh we have to say this uh
for several years uh men and women have
been dressing in such a way as to
attract the opposite sex and they're
dressing not really to glorify God so I
want to encourage people to really ask
yourselves before you step out of that
house uh am I going to by the way I'm
dressing cause somebody to sin this is a
a responsibility because the way you're
dressing may cause somebody to sin be
you men or be your women so I want to
encourage you to really really take this
into prayer and not go anywhere not even
in a supermarket uh in any way that will
not bring glory to God let our let the
way we dress let the way we talk Let The
Way We Walk let that bring glory to God
God and not draw attention to ourselves
am look at 1 Corinthians 14:40 let all
things be done decently and in order uh
now this is applied to some things going
on at um about speaking in tongues at
that particular time but it's a
principle let all things be done
decently and in order Ecclesiastes 5 1
and 2 walk prudently when you go to the
house of God and draw near to hear
rather than to give the sacrifice of
fools for they do not know that they do
evil look at this do not be rash with
your mouth and let not your heart utter
anything hly before God for God is in
heaven and you on Earth then therefore
let your Words Be Few Be Few so even our
words we have to take into consideration
especially when we are in the house of
God so again I want to go back to the
clothing sometimes men just point at
women but uh men are a fa to in the way
they dress yes I know there are ladies
that the skirts have has seemed to go up
higher and higher and tight and this
causes distraction and please take into
consideration you're in the house of the
Lord dress in a way that will bring
honor and glory to the Lord amen amen
thank you sir all right brother Mor
morone here's your second question thank
you I'm reading conflict of the ages and
I'm and am currently in the section
entitled The Plan of
Redemption there is a phrase regarding
regarding Christ leaving his glory to
take upon himself human nature this was
a mystery the sinless intelligences of
other of other world's desire to
understand my question is are there any
Bible passages that might described who
these other intelligences are that's
from Cheryl in Illinois who texted that
to us great question Cheryl thank you
for texting that to
us and um let me answer it this way here
first I'm going
to help us to see that we um don't know
everything but according to the
Wikipedia there are 200 billion to two
trillion galaxies in our observable
universe wow our Milky Way galaxy which
has our solar system in it rotates in a
spherical pattern and you know how long
it takes to go around one time 250
million years you know here's our solar
system in that so it's taking 250
million years to go around one time in
the uh Milky Way
galaxy and you know we used to think
that the solar system uh rotated around
the earth that because Aristotle he made
the statement that the Earth was the
center of the universe and the sun moon
and planets all fixed stars were they
revolved around the earth and it took a
thousand years for mankind to realize
realiz that this planet isn't the center
of the
universe and so that took a lot of Pride
I mean there was a lot of Pride holding
that back so that we could come to this
other conclusion well here's some texts
that could allude to the idea of other
inhabited planets let me start with this
explanation in in Luke chapter 3 uh from
verse 30 23 to 38 it's the genealogy of
Jesus Christ and I'll start with 23 and
Jesus himself began to be about 30 years
of age being as it was supposed the son
of Joseph so it starts with Joseph and
then it goes through his genealogy which
was the son of Heely but going down to
38 which was the son of enus which was
the son of Seth which was the son of
Adam which was the son of God so
evidently the person that was created on
the planet was called the Son of God so
going to job 1:6 now there was a day
when the sons of
God came to present themselves before
the Lord and Satan came also among them
so here's the sons of God the created
beings of the planet the first created
being and then in job 38:4 to7 sons of
God shouted for Joy before the
foundations of the earth so even before
this Earth there were sons of God coming
as he's telling job this and then
Hebrews 1 and 2 or 1 verse 2 by whom
also he made the worlds so more than one
world world that God created more than
one like Earth so Colossians 1:16 And1
17 he created all things visible and
invisible so even though we can't see
them he created so it takes some faith
for sure but these are texts that could
elude that way and then Luke
15:4 the parable of the lost sheep the
shepherd left the 99 sheep who hadn't
gone astray to rescue the one lost sheep
and we can think of Jesus leaving the
rest to come to this one Lost World to
save us amen thank you again for the
question amen thank you sir all right
sister Shel I've got your second
question what does Romans 8:29 mean I'm
confused by the word predestined as it
sounds contrary to our Free Will that's
from Ben who emailed that to us oh been
great question and I'm eager to answer
it let's back up to Romans 8:28 you
can't really separate 28 and 29 verse 8
Romans 8:28 is Our Hope
it says we know that all things work
together for good for those who love God
to those who are called according to his
purpose you know through the gospel God
calls us to Salvation we know first
Timothy 2:4 it says that he wants all
men to be saved so it's born again
Christians who are identified as the
called that God is going to work all
things together for our good and John 11
12 and
13 it says that as many as receive
Christ Jesus to them he gave the the
power the right to become the children
of God so
now here we have Romans 8:28 our hope
he's going to work out all things
together for our good
amen but what does that mean it's Romans
8:29 is our destiny for those he
fornew he also predestined to be
conformed to the image of his son that
he might be the firstborn among many
Brethren Christ came to save us from our
sin not in our sin right so he came to
restore righteousness in us and it's the
only way it can be restored as
righteousness by faith but God
foreordained that word he predestined us
he foreordained he planned he determined
in advance that all who accepted Christ
as their Savior and became his children
those called would be conformed to the
image of Jesus he infuses us with his
strength to walk in the pathway of
Christ's righteousness you know 2
Corinthians 5:17 says if anyone is in
Christ he's a new creation the old is
gone the new has come we don't always
feel like that but let me tell you
something that you've got to accept that
by faith that Philippians 1:6 says he
will complete the good work he's begun
in youh now God will never interfere
with your free will so when it's talking
about predestined it's just his plan but
he never interferes with your free will
you must choose to yield to the leading
of the Holy Spirit Romans
84 we're going to read Romans 8:14
through1
17 as many as are led by the spirit of
God these are the sons of God for you
did not receive the spirit of bondage
again to fear but you receive the spirit
of adoption by whom we cry out amen AB
father that's like saying Daddy God
wants to be your papa he puts his spirit
in you so that you can cry
out and the spirit himself Bears witness
with our spirit that we are children of
God if children then heirs Heirs of God
join HS with Christ see Believers are
predestined to become like Jesus
Hallelujah and like him we will will
Delight to do God's Will and follow his
commands and I love love Isaiah
488 where God said oh if you don't only
follow my commands he says then your
peace will flow like a river and your
righteousness like waves of the sea amen
oh I love how you answer that thank you
so much sister all
right well Pastor deny I've got
your your third question but before
before I give you that I want to real
real quickly remind you at n how you can
participate you can do it one of three
ways you can email us at bible QA at
3abn.org
do I know Jesus has come into my heart
that's from Jean in Arizona who texted
that to us thank you Jean this is a
wonderful wonderful question and I just
praise the Lord that you're asking it
because um it it shows that you have
made you decided to uh have something
different than what your life has been
you want Jesus in your heart that's a
wonderful thing and I hope everyone
listening uh desires to have Jesus in
his or her heart I start with Revelation
3:20 which says behold I stand at the
door and knock if anyone hears my voice
and opens the door I will come into him
and dine with him and he with me so this
is a promise that if you say to Jesus I
want you in my heart he will come in
he's not going to knock the door down
he's going to knock so that you will let
him in and you have chosen to do that so
I praise the Lord for that and I just
hope everyone else does now what happens
how do you know well you will have new
desires new motives you no longer want
to live the way you used to live you
want to give up those things and then
begins the process of the Lord showing
you step by step uh how to it's time to
leave this uh and and and You by
cooperating with him he will give you
the power to leave those old things Jean
that brought you down that brought you
pain and suffering and little by little
you will see that you have Greater Joy
you are enjoying God's peace you will
have a desire to learn more about God by
reading the scriptures you will want to
know oh when is church service I you
will want to be there and so you will
have new desires new motives and your
heart will have greater and greater joy
as you know Jesus Christ is coming to
deliver you from the sufferings of this
world but while we are here we need to
face different difficulties trials and
the Lord promises to be there with us
notice what Jesus says in John
14:27 peace I live with you my peace I
give to you not as the world gives do I
give to you let not your heart be
troubled neither Let It Be Afraid so one
of the things you should experience is
the peace of God especially as you are
reading the scriptures you can even have
a sensing that God is with you this is a
marvelous thing so I want to
uh ask you continue in prayer continue
reading the scriptures and God is going
to open to you wonderful things you will
learn things and you will desire more
you will desire more the more time you
spend with the Lord the more you will
want to know about him and and also uh
how do you know Jesus has entered in
your heart you will have such joy that
you will want to share with others amen
that God has made a difference in your
life you you have that burning desire to
share with others so uh please let us
know how things are going WR to us and
perhaps you have another question you
wanted to send to 3M Bible Q&A uh with
God's grace we will endeavor to answer
your question amen amen thank you sir
all right brother morone here's your
third
question I know that God gave us the
gift of marital sexual relations for
procreation my husband and I are both
well well past the childbearing age but
we still enjoy our sexual relationship
are we sinning that's from Mary in Iowa
who texted that to us that's a good
question Mary and just right off the bat
no you're not sinning I'll show you here
in um in the Bible in uh Genesis chapter
17 and verse 17 Genesis
177 where
Abraham you remember he was supposed to
be the father of many nations and he
eventually was but 17:17 says then
Abraham fell on his face and laughed and
said in his heart shall a child be born
unto him that is 100 years old and shall
Sarah that is 90 years old bear so you
got a 100-year old man and a 90y old
woman and to know that you're Barren you
have to be having sexual relations to
know that you can't have children right
so that we've got that one and the 18
verse
10-13 and this is and he said I will
certainly return this is God speaking to
Abraham according to the time of life
and lo Sarah thy wife shall have a son
and Sarah heard it in the tent door
which was behind him now Abraham and
Sarah were old and well stricken in age
and it ceased to be with Sarah after the
manner of women meaning she was going
through menopause couldn't have children
anymore
and then we have
Zacharias uh in Luke chap 1 Luke 1: 6
and
7 where we have John the P John the
Baptist's parents here Luke 1 and verse
6 and they were both righteous before
God walking in all the Commandments and
ordinances of the Lord blameless and
they had no child because that Elizabeth
was Barren and they were both now well
stricken in years so they were old
people but again to be able to realize
that you can't have kids you have to be
having sexual relations so these are two
older people that were having relations
here's uh 13 it says but the angel said
unto him fear not Zacharias for thy
prayer is heard and thy wife Elizabeth
shall bear thee a son and thou shalt
call his name John and then 14 and thou
shalt have joy and gladness and many
shall reice at his birth and then 18 and
Zachariah said unto the angel whereby
shall I know this for I am an old man
and my wife well stricken in years so
anyway they were still having relations
there so you don't have to worry about
being U sinning and there's this uh
scripture here in First Corinthians
chapter 7 it says uh defraud ye not one
the other except it be with con sent for
a time that you may give yourselves to
fasting and prayer and come together
again and that has to do with in verse
four the wife hath not power of her own
body but the husband and likewise also
the husband have not power of his own
body but the wife's talking about sexual
relation so good question amen amen for
it to be enjoyable didn't he yeah amen
yes yes all right sister Shelley here's
your third
question should we pray to God in our
minds especially our plans and petitions
so so Satan can't hear and try to answer
them impersonating God or try to damage
our plans one day my prayer was answered
and I didn't know if it was God or Satan
because I prayed for it out loud and the
answer left Bittersweet
consequences I've decided since to pray
in my mind for things I don't want to
get confused about it seems like common
sense to me now but I'd like to know if
this is what we should be doing or if it
doesn't matter and that's from jariel in
Puerto Rico who emailed that to us Jarel
that is an interesting question I
certainly don't put myself up as an
expert on anything but I'll tell you
there's nowhere in the Bible that God
tells us to pray pray silently he tells
us to go Jesus says to go into your
closet but he's not he just saying don't
you know get out of out of people's
sight and pray it doesn't mean that it's
silent if God knew it was going to be a
problem I think he would have instructed
us
clearly um there's many instances in the
scripture of people praying out loud
Solomon's dedication of the temple in 2
Chronicles chapter 6 I think Elijah
Mount Carmel probably was praying out
loud First Kings 18 Jesus prayed out
loud in Matthew 11 Luke 10 John 12 12
and in John 11 he says 41-43 Jesus said
then they took away the Stone from the
place where the dead man was lying Jesus
lifted up his eyes and said father I
thank you that you have heard me and I
know that you always hear me he's
praying out loud but because of the
people who are standing by I said this
that they may believe that you sent me
now when he'd said these things he cried
out with a loud voice Lazarus come forth
and then after Christ's Ascension the
Believers in the upper room were praying
out loud in Acts 1 at acts 16 verse 25
Paul and Silas were praying and singing
hymns to God and the prisoners were
listening to them Paul prayed with the
Elders of Ephesus in Acts 20 and verse
36 so what am I saying in Daniel chapter
10 there is a scene in Daniel chapter 10
that shows us that Satan's trying to
interfere with
prayer um again when I said Jesus told
us to go to a prayer closet he's just
saying don't be showy like the Pharisees
here's what I will tell you because I
can't other than saying I don't find
anything in the Bible that clearly
commands us to pray silently I feel
protected when I'm praying out loud
and I think it's because I start with
Thanksgiving and praise Psalm 22:3 says
God inhabits the Praises of his people
and guess what the devil cannot stand in
his presence so David journaled his
prayers he wrote them out that's what
the Psalms are that's right I Journal my
prayers the devil could certainly see
that couldn't he but here's the point I
know that God's got his hand of
protection on me if I'm praying for
something to get an answer I don't think
it's the devil cuz he doesn't want he
doesn't want God to get the glory but if
you feel more comfortable praying
silently pray
silently amen okay sister thank you very
much all right Pastor deny I've got your
final
question how can Satan be a dragon in
heaven if Dragons aren't supposed to be
real that's from Crystal who texted that
to us well thank you Crystal that is a
good question in essence uh we have to
ask ourselves where this idea of dragon
comes from uh when you go to Revelation
12 and I believe this is what you're
talking about uh because well it says
there in Revelation 12:3 and another
sign appeared in heaven Behold a great
fiery red dragon having seven heads and
10 horns and seven diadems on his heads
so this is where this is this is where
we find it and and of course it's found
in Revelation 1613 and revelation 22
verse chapter 20:2 it's the same Greek
word and the Greek word is really draon
which is where uh the word comes from in
English and by the time the translation
of the Bible takes place the word Dragon
was basically a common word and when
they looked at this Greek word they say
oh this must mean a dragon but a dragon
is as us said
a uh fictitious creature uh the way
people commonly believe a dragon is and
of course there are the ideas of dragon
dragons flying and and spewing out
Flames this is all fiction like you said
they're not supposed to be real but in
Greek the word the Greek word is really
talking about a large
Serpent and for example uh there are
large serpents like an anaconda I've
seen condas that are huge creatures so
uh here is really talking about a large
serpent but when again when you come to
the time of translations the common idea
of a dragon they use the word Dragon
it's really a creature a large
serpent-like creature that is being
described here so there's no there's no
um this is just used as a symbol of the
devil is the devil a large serpent uh no
the devil remember was before a an angel
an angel that was next to the throne of
God and this Angel rebelled against God
and this Angel became the devil and the
dragon is used as a serpent why because
it does things to try to destroy and
this is why the word dragon is there so
this is what we can share with you and I
hope this is of help to you amen thank
you very much sir all right brother
morone here's your final
question I'm confused when Jesus Christ
was pierced at his side it mentions
blood and water came out of his body
where did the water come from how did
the water get into his body did our
heavenly father die of a broken heart
that's from Jay who emailed that to us
that's a good question the Curiosity
that's really good thank you for sending
that in Jay well let's see if our god
did die have a broken
heart you know he did God the the father
did pour out his wrath upon his son
there on the cross where he's crying out
my God my God why have you forsaken
me then it says that he cried it is
finished let's pick that up in chapter
19 of John John
19 and verses
32-34 and you know it's kind of
interesting the uh Jewish people that
was coming to be the Sabbath it was
Friday evening and they didn't want a
body to be on the cross so they started
breaking the legs of these different uh
you know the other men that were on the
cross with Jesus the two thieves in
verse 32 then the so came the soldiers
and break the legs of the first and of
the other which was crucified with him
but when they came to
Jesus and saw that he was dead already
they break not his legs was kind of UN
heard of to die of crucifixion that
quickly the reason they broke the legs
was you know they would what you know
you got your hands you're trying to
breathe and so you have to push up with
your legs and then take a breath and so
by breaking their legs that basically
they suffocated they could not take a
breath in anymore to be able to stay
alive so uh verse 34 but one of the
soldiers with a spear cuz they saw well
he's dead dead but just to make sure he
stabs him in his side and forth with
came there out blood and water you say
why how did water get ins sign Jesus
we're drinking water every day aren't we
well it's kind of interesting the way
the body you know the um I look at that
Jesus died of a broken heart God the son
you wondered if God the father died of a
broken heart but but I believe God the
son did die of a broken heart so you
know your heart with so much stress you
know he actually it says he fell dying
to the Earth in the Garden of Gethsemane
but then there was an angel came and
kind of revived him so now he's on the
cross and this final pressure of all the
sins the weight of the whole world Upon
Jesus that stress just I look at
ruptured his heart you know like you've
heard of an aortic aneurism within one
minute all your blood pours into your
body cavity wherever that aneurysm might
be and so when they stabbed him in the
side it came out and I was trying to get
some blood here cuz I was I'm a
registered nurse and I used to draw
blood and when you set blood on a
counter or something it'll actually
separate the red cor pusles which have
the hemog globin in them heemi means
iron so that's heavier so I don't know
if you can see that or not but uh it
separates the red core pusle has dropped
to the bottom and the serum which is 90%
over 90% water so I think that's what
happened when he stabbed him and he'd
been dead at least a half an hour
because it takes that long to drop the
red cor pusle thanks for the question
thank you thank you very much
sir all right sister Shelley here's your
final question very little is mentioned
about Eve's
salvation I'm curious as to whether she
was saved or not was she forgiven for
her transgression and will she make it
to Heaven that's from David who texted
that to us David this is such a
wonderful question I'm so excited to
answer it in the first 11 chapters of
Genesis there is 2,000 years of the
Earth's history recorded in just 11
chapters so there's not a lot of detail
one thing we do know that as soon as
Adam and Eve sinned the Lord showed up
and announced his Everlasting Covenant
in Genesis 3:15
he's addressing the serpent he says I'll
put imity between you and the woman and
between your seed and her seed he's
going to bruise your head and you shall
bruise his heel so here we've got God is
predicting the end of the cosmic
conflict the great
controversy by the promised seed who is
coming and within context of this we
find in Genesis 3:20 within context of
this event Eve is now
announced as she's dubbed the mother of
all living
so verses Genesis 3:21 says that Adam
and his wife for them the Lord made
tunics of skin and clothe them you know
what this is God initiated
the
substitutionary system the sacrificial
system of for righteousness by faith
when God had to clothe them because they
were naked they lost his shakina
covering they were naked God had to kill
a little animal and this is where I know
you can really and I if you haven't read
spotless experiencing the Everlasting
Covenant I enourage you to get that you
can get them free from
3abn but what happened is this
sacrificial lamb pointed and the
substitutionary system
pointed to the coming Messiah the
deliverer that he promised in Genesis
3:15 you know Revelation 138 says that
Jesus is the Lamb who was slain from the
foundation of the world and it's been
promised all along this was our
deliverer so when God instituted this
sacrificial system this
substitutionary
idea he opened the way to righteousness
by faith in the coming
Messiah humans could do nothing to
restore their righteousness after they
sinned what is Isaiah 6 46 what is it
464 or 646 anyway Isaiah says that the
best we can do our righteousness is like
filthy rags before the Lord Isaiah 646
646 thank you see and here's what we see
in the Old Testament Abel followed the
plan of God he's declared righteous
Enoch was translated because God found
him righteous he was translated to
heaven without dying Noah the Bible says
found Grace in God's eyes he obeyed God
Hebrews 11:7 says Noah this is New
Testament talking about Noah said he
became the heir of
righteousness which is according to
Faith the patriarch job was declared by
God to be right ious he trusted God he
believed that he would be resurrected to
see his Redeemer so here's the point
David this is so
wonderful all of these people God
announces his Everlasting Covenant of
righteousness by faith and these Old
Testament people are found righteous by
faith I believe that Adam and Eve were
both made righteous by faith Eve was
dubbed the mother of all living she
expected that this deliverer was going
to come from her they taught their sons
Abel and Cain what the truth was about
the sacrificial substitutionary system
Cain didn't knowy Abel did and the
Bible's clear that they were taught
because it says that
righteous Abel obeyed amen so the point
is yes I think that the weight of
evidence shows that Eve was made
righteous by faith and that she will be
saved amen amen that's great great well
family you can see that we've answered
all these questions from the word of God
here's where we can find our answers I
encourage you to to study God's word you
know we've got a wonderful resource
where you can find these answers from
the word of God on our website it's 3abn
Bible anwers.com have you heard of that
site I want to encourage you check that
site out you can find answers to
questions like the Antichrist you can
find questions to uh answers to
questions like on on baptism um what
happens when you die Heaven questions on
heaven and and the judgment a lot of
questions can be found here on this
website so I want to encourage you to
check out 3abn Bible anwers.com
so don't go away we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org panelists sister
Shelly I just want you to know how much
God loves you and don't ever forget that
if you understand how much he loves you
you will love him back and that's what
he's looking for amen Amen brother
morone well that one question where we
were questioning why God was killing
people and uh didn't really you don't
really have enough time in 3 minutes to
really expound on that but God is love
amen and he's not willing that any
should perish but that all should come
to eternal life and then you know as far
as someone uh coming to a point in their
life where they're never going to change
and they'll just always be miserable
because of the guilt of sin that they
carry you could look at it as merciful
that God puts them we could say destroys
them puts them to sleep or whatever
however you want to say it but uh so
then it's merciful of God to do that uh
you know you have people that are so
tortured in their mind that they pull up
a gun and go to a policeman try to shoot
the policeman so the policeman will
shoot them and kill them cuz the
torturing in the inner mind anyway
that's the way God is love amen thank
you amen deny I would like to share
about you know the one thing to know if
you have Jesus in your heart from
Ephesians chapter 3 beginning in verse
14 reading quickly for this reason I bow
my knees to the father of our Lord Jesus
Christ for from whom the whole family in
Heaven and Earth is named that he would
Grant Grant you according to the riches
of his glory to be strengthened with
might through his spirit in the Inner
Man you know God wants to dwell in you
through his holy spirit this happens by
faith
notice that Christ May dwell in your
hearts through faith that you being
rooted and grounded in love may be able
to comprehend with all the saint what is
the width and length and depth and
height to know the love of Christ which
passes knowledge that you may be filled
with all the fullness of God what a
great priv it is to know Jesus and you
can know that he's dwelling in your
heart invite him every day and through
his Spirit by faith you can be
strengthened with might am amen amen
well thanks for joining us I want to
leave you with this fun scripture song
you shall love the Lord your God with
all your heart with all your soul and
with all your strength you shall love
the Lord your God with all your heart
with all your soul and with all your
strength Deuteronomy 6:5 Deuter onomy 6
verse5 thanks for joining us God bless
God bless amen
[Music]